♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS)
Thanks for joining us
for the final episode
of Insecure's after show,
the Wine Down.
Woo!
On this very special occasion,
we are going
to unpack
our epic series finale,
and why we ended the show
the way we did.
So, Issa, are you ready
to dive in?
I'm so ready to dive in.
-Oh, my God!
-Final clink! Well,
second-to-last clink.
So this final episode
goes through
a series of time jumps
and tells our story
as we pass through months
and even years
of our character's lives.
And now that all is revealed,
we see the way
that things close out
for our characters.
So you wrote the final episode,
which is very fitting,
given the history of the show,
of course.
So tell us,
in all honesty,
when did you know you wanted
Issa to walk
into the sunset with Lawrence?
From the very jump
of writing the season.
I think I knew that
I didn't want them together,
and I was very confident
about that.
I was like,
"I want more for our girl."
And I felt like we had
told their love story,
and it ended tragically,
but I still wanted
a healthy love story.
And so I was like,
"It's gonna work
for Issa and Nathan."
The more and more we started
going into it,
I was like,
"That's not--"
I felt like Issa,
like, "I love him
but I know who my guy is."
We toyed with, like,
"Is it Nathan?
Is it Lawrence?
Is it Crenshawn?
Is it--" You know what I mean?
Is it somebody
that we just pick up
that's a random person
that we haven't followed,
right?
Because we know we're gonna
end on Issa and Molly, right?
We always knew that.
But it still felt like
the level of investment
of the person is gonna be
like the most interesting
version of that, is Lawrence.
And you and I talked early on
'cause one of the things
we wanted to explore
about people being okay, right,
was this idea
of, "Well, I didn't get
the things I wanted,"
but is that okay?
And I think that was
the journey.
I didn't get the season two
fantasy
I thought I was gonna get
with Lawrence.
The end of season two,
we're moving in, we're married,
we have a child together.
And in a way, you get that,
it's just not the way
you thought it was gonna
look like.
But are you gonna be okay?
Yeah, I think so.
Obviously, when you're
ending a series, right,
there's all this pressure
of finales
that have come before you.
The Sopranos finale,
and how people feel
about that,
or Game of Thrones finale.
You don't want to end it
where everything
is wrapped up all cute,
because that doesn't seem right,
but you also don't want
to end it in a place
where I've been watching
five years, like,
to feel sad.
But you want to be honest,
right?
And I think Amy Aniobi,
one of our writers
and our director,
really freed us
from the pressure
of ending the show.
She was like, "Guys,
let's just end it
as if these character's lives
are just gonna continue on."
It's just weird
jumping out the plane--
We're not landing the plane,
we're just jumping out of it.
And the ride still
continues.
And that's what, I think,
felt really satisfying
was that it took us--
Sometimes it's not about
where you end up,
it's really how you get there.
And say that if you and I,
or us in the room,
are having real debates
in real time,
we want to put that in the show.
And the debate that
the girls actually have
in 507 of,
"If I don't want
to be a dumb bitch,"
you and I actually
had that dialogue that
you and Tiffany have.
But that is the journey
people have to go through,
and it took a year for her
or whatever time
for her to process,
"I had to grow."
And we wanted to use
Molly's mom passing,
not just as the sort of
dramatic thing that happens,
but it actually kind of,
in some way,
refocuses our characters
on what's important
at the end of the day.
But life is too short.
And you sort of say that
when you're talking
to Lawrence,
when you call,
for his birthday,
and it certainly resonates
at the end of the episode
when you guys are having
that last moment together
before Molly's wedding.
So... it is really nice
to see all those things
kind of dovetail
for these character's growth.
So many tragic life events
have pulled friendships apart,
and I know that we didn't
want that for Issa and Molly,
but it could still
make it harder to get together
and harder to forge
that bond they've carried
throughout these seasons.
One thing we talk about
in this show
is this love story
between you and Molly.
And there's a moment
in the show
when you are helping her
out of her dress,
but it is the last moment
we see you guys
actually together
in the frame, right?
So I'm curious what that day
was like,
and what does it mean
to you to have a show
where for the most part
of this show,
these women were like
the best of friends,
family, like sisters?
Everything.
I think about my own friendships
and I think about my friendship
that's developed with Yvonne
over the course of six years
creating this.
And it was such an
emotional day.
It was Issa sending
her friend off
into the next chapter
of her life.
It was this moment of them
kind of reckoning
and acknowledging everything
they had been through.
They found each other,
and they've loved each other
through all of their flaws,
and that "Thank you"
meant so much.
When we started season one,
could you imagine
that fans would be
so invested,
or that they'd harass you
online or in-person,
to make the show longer,
or get mad
when Issa made life decisions,
or dated certain men?
Did you think it would
just be this?
I mean, you know,
we were in such a vacuum
in that first season,
especially.
We just wanted
to stay on the air.
We just wanted to tell
our stories
and tell it the way
we wanted to.
You know, you imagine
this audience
of family and friends
and things like that,
but you don't know
who's going to be watching
the show,
and you hope they like it.
But I get fake annoyed,
I get real annoyed,
but it really is
a true blessing
to have people
so invested.
These characters are a part
of people's lives
in such a rich way.
And you can only dream
of creating
characters like that.
You know, a lot of times
if you're
in the white world of Hollywood,
if you're making a Black show
it's like, "Let's get
every Black person
every Black person knows
already."
'Cause we just want
to make sure
people know these people,
right?
But white shows kind
of get a chance
to take a chance on an indie
person you never heard of
before, right?
And I think that was
a thing
that I thought you were
so smart in the beginning,
was, "Let's do what
Spike Lee did
and find people that will
grow out of that,
and the next wave
of Black talent."
And so, you got
to personalize
and make Issa be whoever
you wanted Issa to be,
for yourself, same with Molly,
same with Lawrence.
It's like they felt like
every-people, right?
And so I think that helped
always keep the show
feeling like, "Oh,
that's not Denzel Washington
as his dad."
So I think that helps you
become more invested.
When we first met
and sat down,
not too far from here,
actually,
for me, my goal was always,
"Hey, I want to make sure
you get to tell the stories
you want to tell."
But you obviously had
a different challenge, too,
because you had to adapt it
from a web-series, right?
Into a totally different form
in so many ways.
The web-series was what it was,
and I wanted to create
something new for this network.
And I don't know that I had
the expectations
of where I wanted
the series to go,
where I wanted every
character to go.
I knew the journey I wanted
to take them on,
but this has exceeded
everything I imagined
that it would be
in the best way.
And I'm just forever grateful
for that.
What I think is so great
about this show
is getting to watch it
change and grow
with each person
that we brought on.
So I read the script one way,
but then we brought Melina on,
and it elevated it
to another place.
And we just continue to see
this thing grow and grow.
So just to piggy-back
your point,
I totally agree with that.
Yeah, the people
behind the scenes
-made the show what it is.
-PRENTICE PENNY: Agree.
You know, the city in which
we both grew up, L.A.,
is a huge part of the show.
And we always talked about
the way
that Scorsese or Spike Lee
or Woody Allen
sort of make these
love letters to New York, right?
Why was it important for you
to make a show
that was a sort of love letter,
not just to L.A.,
but the specific part
of L.A.
that normally doesn't
get seen?
I think it's that.
It's what you just said,
and I feel like L.A.
is always represented
as either Hollywood,
the glamour and glitz,
or the hood,
and the in-between
doesn't really exist,
especially in between
as it relates to us.
And that was so important
for me to portray.
The finale was initially,
half of it
was going to be in Morocco,
three-fourths of it
was gonna be in Morocco,
just to pay off
Issa and Molly's
the fantasy destination.
And it was a great episode,
but it wasn't in L.A.
and it just didn't
feel right.
So we wanted to give L.A.
a good ending as well.
Yeah, L.A., we also had
a Rihanna impersonating--
(CHUCKLES) Ribabba!
R.I.P. Ribabba!
R.I.P. Ribabba! Our fake
Rihanna concert in Morocco.
-So...
-So, Prentice, in your opinion,
is Issa finally secure?
I think so.
But to say the question,
the word, "final"
has a weird thing on it, right?
I think you and I
have always talked about,
and I think we talked
about this day one,
about the series,
was that the real ending
of the show was when
you get secure
in your insecurities,
and knowing that
insecurities won't ever
leave, right?
And so it's understanding that,
"I'll go through ups and downs
and all that,
but I don't have
to have these sweeping
reactions."
In the first two seasons,
Issa's always like,
"This thing happens,
I'mma be a no-fucks bitch.
Or I'mma be a this,
I'mma be a that."
As opposed to being like,
"You know what?
I'm gonna ride this wave
a little bit,
and just be uncomfortable
as it's uncomfortable
and then grow out of it."
And so, if I was to say,
I think she finally recognizes
that real security comes
from understanding
there kind of is no final
version of being fully secure.
Well said.
To our dedicated viewers,
we thank you guys
for riding with us
for the past five seasons.
And we hope that you enjoyed
this journey
as much as we did.
We will miss you.
Insecure, we hope,
lives in your hearts forever.
Thank you, guys,
for rocking with us,
and for letting
these characters
into your homes
every Sunday.
Thank you.
Nobody has to tweet,
"Make it an hour" anymore.
(LAUGHING)
-Thank y'all.
-Bye, y'all, thank you.
-Cheers.